LAUREN MERRIMAN: So my
name's Lauren Merriman.
I'm a senior right now.
I'm actually
graduating in February.
I took this class
because I decided
I really want to
make video games,
and this is a good
class to take.
My team is seven people,
and we are mostly seniors.
We made a game about
[? cholera. ?] The other team
focused on the younger 8 to 13.
And we focused on a little bit
older-- about 13 and above--
so we could have a little bit
more complicated mechanics
and text where we needed it.
So we didn't really have
to rely on figuring out
how to make everything
really easy to read.
So it uses English
that assumes someone
who speaks English could read
and understand very easily.
And our game is a strategy game.
It's real time,
where the days are--
you have to survive a year
and the days are automatic.
So you have you go and take care
of four different localities,
and give them either
soap or water containers
or electrolytes
to help heal them.
And later on you
get boiling water.
And you just have to take
care of these four localities
for a year.
So we learned early
on, the class, you
start by your first project
is just paper prototype.
And then after, you have
to make digital prototypes,
but they usually expect you
to have a paper prototype.
And for this one, they
expected you to do it however
you wanted to.
And so we started off
with a paper prototype,
and we sort of then quickly
implemented it digitally.
Because there were certain
things that doing it with paper
would take a long time
to make a calculation.
But we originally
had part of it was
you could see on the
screen what the localities,
where they were.
And then you would try
to implement things.
But we didn't have a screen
to help you select that.
And so you'd tell
us what you pick,
and then we quickly put it
in the game and reset it.
So that's what we
originally did, and it
was really hard to do it
that way because people
going from the screen to a paper
prototype, they were confused.
And they didn't really
see how things interacted.
So then our next big thing
was make it all digital.
And in the presentation
that you saw,
we had that original shot of
what the game looked like when
we had it all digital.
And it was just a really
poorly designed GUI.
And it was hard to read
and hard to understand
and people were really
struggling with it.
So I actually was the one
who redesigned the GUI,
and then it went through
a couple of iterations
with the new GUI.
So we decided how to make it
the most clear, and I sat down
and I looked at other strategy
games, mostly Civilization.
I'm actually not a big
strategy game player,
so I actually had to
go look around and see
what other places do.
And I stole a little
bit from Civilization,
and a few other games that just
had good elements of design
that looked clear and
understandable-- even
to someone who's never
touched the game before.
And so that's what I
wanted in our game.
So that's why we implemented
it the way we did.
And then the game kind of
turned into the way it is now.
So one of the biggest things
is I'm not a programmer.
So I was doing either design or
product management or the scrum
master-- is what
they call it, which
is someone who has to
take care of the team
and make everything
fit together.
Whether it's including art and
music and coding-- making sure
all those elements fit together
into one cohesive whole.
And so that's sort of the
role that I started to do
and then really liked doing.
At first I thought, on
some of these projects,
I should take on a
coding role to try
to force myself to learn.
But I realized I
didn't really want to.
I really liked doing
this role instead.
But you learn it's really hard.
Especially in a class setting
where people aren't really
tied monetarily to this class.
You can't lose your job
if you don't do your job.
You can do poorly in the class,
but because it's a group thing,
you might not do that poorly
because the group presented
like, this is our game.
And so unless you specifically
call out that person,
they're still going
to get credit for it.
And so it was really difficult
as the product manager
to get people to
do what they said
they were going to do
in a timely manner,
and get people to
respond to my emails.
And so it was really
something that you
have to get people to
understand-- especially
towards the end where we
didn't have a lot done,
and we needed to change a lot--
that there's not a lot of time,
and there's still a lot to do.
And then when I finally
got everyone in a meeting
and they all sat down, we talked
about this, like, everyone,
you just heard it-- oh,
that's when that's due?
So I finally got people
in gear, and so I
wish I could have done this
earlier in the semester.
It was just this project.
With the other projects,
people didn't usually
fall into that trap as much
because it was only two weeks.
So two weeks doesn't give
you a lot of time to fail.
You've got to do it quickly.
And but when it was eight
weeks, it was a lot of time
and so people are like oh we can
push this off a little further.
It was really hard.
I actually ended up having--
I talked to the professors
to try to figure out a way to
get my team to listen to me.
And it was still
really hard, but once
you finally get everyone
together and really lay
it out very clearly, like the
clarity is what I was missing.
I thought I was
being very clear,
and this is how things would do.
And even with the way
I was assigning tasks,
I thought I was being
very clear and I wasn't.
I was really missing
concrete details.
I said, guys, implement
this idea-- implement
that you can take the actions.
But I didn't tell them
this is how it should look.
This is how it should feel.
And so when it got
implemented, it
wasn't what I thought it was.
And I was like, this is
really disappointing.
This is really ugly.
So when I sat down and
redid it and then told them
exactly what I expected,
things got done faster.
Because, like we said
in our presentation,
people weren't really
motivated for this game.
And so having the motivation
and really vague instructions
made it that people wouldn't
do it until-- you put that off.
That's a really hard task.
I need to figure out
what she expects,
and then I need to do it,
and I don't really want to.
So that's something
you put off to the end.
And so when you give
people clear instructions,
it makes it easier
just to do it.
Because they're like,
oh, that's simple.
I can do that really quickly.
And so I think that was the
easiest way is when you really
set clear instructions,
clear deadlines,
and you can't really
punish people.
There's no way of slapping
them on the wrist when
they don't do it.
You can just not
assign them work.
And you move it
to somebody else.
And eventually people
realize that they weren't
getting assigned any work.
And they realized just,
hey, I'm not actually
doing anything for this.
Can I have work?
And I said, you have
to do it by this time,
and if you don't, then
we're pretty screwed.
So really doing
that, really making
sure you have clear deadlines
and shifting the work
around so that people who will
do the work and can do the work
and have the time to do
work are getting the work.
And the people who either just
are doing the work or maybe
don't have the time that
week because that also
happens, where one week
will be really tough.
So you shift the
work away from them.
So you have to be
better about-- I
think if I had
started being better
about how I gave assigned
work rather than just
evenly dividing it, that really
would help with the project.
So working with
a client was hard
because he was
unavailable a lot.
And the times he
did come to class
he said, if you have
to email me a question,
it better be really
clear and concise,
or we're not going to answer it.
And so luckily,
in the beginning,
we kind of knew what we
wanted to do with our game.
And so we just went
in that direction.
And then whenever
Pablo came into class--
Pablo was our main client.
We also had Ellie, but she was
only in class a couple times,
and so we don't get as
much feedback from her.
So whenever Pablo
came into class,
he told us what
we needed to fix,
and that was the biggest
interaction with him
that we had.
At first, we didn't
really know who
to design it for
because they said,
we need two cholera
games for everybody.
And so we were really
unsure and so finally,
three or four weeks
into the project,
we talked to the
other cholera team
and said, what are you doing?
Because we're going
to do the opposite.
Because they wanted
two games that
would be for different groups,
and so then we did that.
We talked to Pablo the
next time he came in,
and he said, yes,
this is what I want.
So luckily we managed
to guess what he wanted.
It could have gone worse
if we did something
that he didn't want.
So if that had
happened, and he said,
you guys are really going
in the wrong direction,
I think we would have made
sure to email him more.
But most of the time,
he's like, I like
the direction you're going.
You just need to fix
these sorts of things,
so that's what we did.